servus s kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem leute heute mit macht am start und
wir machen heute einen sprung zurück in
der zeit wir machen heute kann sie im
auto cool video können sie denen leute
wir erwarten heute youtuber starter
packs aber anders als man es sonst kennt
ihr seht wir haben hier zwei blöcke
anzetteln und wir machen das jetzt so
wir bekommen von luca also nicht youtube
lokal sondern ein anderer lokaler
befahren jeweils namen von youtube
angesagt und dann müssen wir quasi
rückwärts erraten welche merkmale in dem
starter pack von diesen youtuber drin
sind das heißt wer jetzt zum beispiel
baby kommen würde würde man sagen
babybauch ist wahrscheinlich da julian
kurz wahrscheinlich da vielleicht auch
diese verfehlt wurde geldbündeln stadt
pecs bestehen hier glücklicherweise aus
vier merkmal das heißt wir schreiben uns
mit den namen hören hier vierlinge auch
von dem wir denken dass sie drin sind
und wer am ende mehr hat jake punkt wir
haben mehr punkte hat kriegt ne stelle
das tanzverbot okay noch einmal von
wahnsinn dieses starter packs sind ein
bisschen eltern 2017 tanzverbot
ok also meine merkmale sind zahnlücke
bademantel booster und kolle pizza ich
habe zahnlücke fastfood booster und
bademantel also sind wir relativ nah
beieinander
irgendwie nun fast food kette an einer
zahnbrücke leistet ihren bademantel
booster habe ich noch auf beides falsch
schriftführerin und gewesen ansage am
und mehr des rechtswegs das heißt ich
habe zwei du hast ja dann geht der punkt
der mich nächstes das sollte einfach so
ein jahr
ok und wieder das 2017 fertig ich mache
mir wird stadland youtube wenn der
vorherige junge wie schnell bist du denn
mit diana als auch ich würde sagen luca
sagt die merkmale und wir sagen was wir
haben dann luca schieß los welche
merkmale sind einmal kanzler habe ich
einmal magst aber ich habe schokolade
hatte glitzer dastehen und dass
schokolade gewidmet hast du chocolat
ich hab süßigkeiten ja ich das jetzt
gesagt süßigkeiten auf dem bild ist auf
den punkt das heißt bei 33 beide punkt
221 aktueller stand montana
ist ein auto drin ist die frage ob
einmal mit gesetzen zigaretten einen
punkt ein punkt also der monster energy
habe ich auch mario kart nehme ich nicht
an ich sage da und musik haben
ich hab's network ich habe körper ist
eine snack die ja mit dem volk dafür
haben kleine rote ich habe aber in allen
zigaretten punkt mehr von daher geht das
an mich warum gibst du dir einen punkt
mit freude bekannt dass man bis zum
jahre 2002 steht jetzt die logins und
finden nichts dazu ein
du kannst doch einfach was weglassen
hast du was weggelassen dann keine
deutschen sagen okay ich darüber steuern
wir sehen nichts eingefallen was ist das
denn mein erster punkte so baum weiter
gelockert habe ich auch hast du echt ich
wollte nicht so gemeint heute hätte aber
das ist halt zu einem
alleinstellungsmerkmal also haben auch
andere aber das ist ja wie daran denkt
man auch über gute ist wichtig das
letzte habe ich hab' ich habe einst
mcdonnell ist zusammen ergibt das
macbook als davon geht er mit mir
geführt
dazu zwei ich würde sagen alles oder
nichts okay okay ich habe gerade mit 9 6
vater in den westen gefolgt ist so eine
tolle twitter-seite wieso sex gibt's
gepostet dass solche gesetze aber dann
minecraft expert habe ich habe was hast
du ich habe einen extrem unterziehen
delfine winkel lache alter hast du noch
dicker ich hatte noch was auch ich hatte
noch stieg rauch und nett aber netter
ist auch liebeslieder ja schon damit
leute damit leute ich hab mich jetzt
wieder beruhigt ich dachte heute kriegen
wir für diese letzte runde beide 1 punkt
und es stehe ich seit ich drei leute im
marisa braig umgehst alles leider hilft
mir hast du das hat den loches
geburtstag hinterlässt in dem verweis
von max weibliche intuition und bin ja
auch weibliche intuition haben wollt
dann abonniert diesen kann
sie ist es nicht toll junge neue folge
was geht immer was und verliert damit
was es geht eine drohne challenge
gemacht und ihr könnt in diesem video
sogar einer drohne gewinn leute deswegen
gibt's ab und